4000 emplois nouveaux seront créés en
lorraine c'est ce qu'a annoncé ce matin
laurent fabius qui était à nancy en
compagnie de plusieurs chefs
d'entreprise un nouveau drame chez les
kennedy l'un des fils de l'ancien
sénateur robert kennedy est retrouvé
mort dans une chambre d'hôtel aux états
unis d'éviter les 10 avait été soignée
pour toxicomanes l'euthanasie de nouveau
dans l'actualité après la diffusion en
allemagne fédérale d'un document réalisé
par un cancérologue
vous verrez dans ce journal ce document
qui est terry quand bédié morts avec lui
disparaît l'une des grandes figures du
jazz
mesdames messieurs bonsoir l'actualité
passe ce soir encore par la lorraine le
ministre du redéploiement industriel
était aujourd'hui à nancy où il devait
conformément à ses engagements annoncés
un premier train de mesures concrètes
pour relancer l'activité dans la région
alors beaucoup de chiffres ont circulé
ces dernières semaines et on estime est
à un millier le nombre d'emplois
nouveaux qu'ils allaient être créés dans
le bassin lorrain en fait monsieur
fabius venait avec de bonnes nouvelles
puisque il annoncé tout à l'heure la
création prochaine de 4000 emplois le
détail de ces décisions
avec martin jce en 2000 emplois seront
créés dans les trois ans qui viennent
par le secteur public
la cge alston embauchera dès cette année
viendront ensuite renault la société
alcatel thomson et rhône poulenc chimie
par ailleurs les tranches 3 et 4 de la
centrale nucléaire de cattenom seront
accélérées le secteur privé lui créera
mille emplois grâce à l'implantation
d'une quinzaine d'entreprises parmi
elles une petite pme anglaise
d'ordinateurs individuels qui va
s'installer à longwy
enfin mille emplois seront créés par le
secteur tertiaire ainsi le cnrs
installera en lorraine un centre de
documentation scientifique et technique
alors laurent fabius n'était pas venu
seul en lorraine il était accompagné de
plusieurs chefs d'entreprises
susceptibles de venir s'implanter dans
cette zone de reconversion ce sont eux
entre autres qui vont contribuer à la
création d'emplois
rennes roselyne koskas et laurent
carenzo était du voyage
la journée avait mal commencé pour
laurent fabius
marage de sidérurgistes incidents avec
les forces de police
agressions contre les voitures la
télévision malgré cette tension les
discussions avec les syndicats se
dérouler dans un climat serein
laurent fabius faisait part de ses
propositions et les syndicats avec des
nuances considérer certaines mesures
comme positive pour ton une appréciation
positive sur cet entretien car le
ministre est venu apporter un certain
nombre de précisions à la fois sur le
sur le plan acier pour leur discuter en
lorraine et également pour diversifier
le tissu industriel et
nous avons noté des propositions
concrètes et précises qui doivent
redonner l'espoir à cette population
n'aurait ni gouvernement campe sur ses
positions
donc deux accords est pour nous
nécessité de poursuivre la lui au niveau
de la sidérurgie les mines de fer
lorraine et voire même de tout pour
faire bouger
enfin le gouvernement sur le placié
deuxième chose qu'il faut dit entre nous
honnêtement et les propositions diverses
applications industrielles des
propositions concernant des mesures
financières ou techniques qui nous
semble à première vue intéressante si
elle se confiant car on est méfiant
lorraine on a déjà été échaudé là aussi
il faudra que l'action du travailleur
qui permette que se concrétise ce qui a
été promis
concernant celui concernant la
diversification
dans l'après midi le calme revenait sur
la place stanislas et à la préfecture
laurent fabius présenté au conseil
régional
les industriels décidé à investir en
lorraine
il était là au grand peuple et
représentant renaud poulin la cgsp
bronze et même un investisseur anglais
pas mieux à leurs e mails que déjà de
personnes décident de créer 800 emplois
et qui explique ce choix
un épisode qui se posait était de savoir
si il est l économique et rentable de
l'installer en france
traditionnellement pour cette activité
en effet la concurrence nationale
généralement implantés activités dans
les pays à bas coût de main d'oeuvre
il se trouve que depuis quelques années
les conditions industrielles ont changé
les procédés sont devenus beaucoup plus
robotisée bulls ont baptisé et un calcul
économique serré montre des conditions
très très serré on peut justifier un
investissement rentable de ce type
d'activité en france
alors selon vous la france pourquoi pas
de haine parce qu'il ya exonération de
charges sociales
c'est bien sûr que ça rende bien entendu
dans le hall dont les comptes dans les
considérations bien tableau de chasse
sociale et financière bien sûr à la fin
de cette journée chargée
laurent fabius tirer le bilan des
discussions il faut qu'on essaie d'unir
nos bonnes volontés c'est un petit peu
le message que j'ai voulu faire passer
c'est à dire volonté on a la volonté
avec les lorrains d'essayer de te s'en
sortir
continuité parce que c'est pas l'action
d'un jour c'est une action qui est sur
plus long terme et efficacité parce que
n'est pas là pour parler du sexe des
anges et pour avancées concrètes et
l'impression d'avoir été en complètement
entendu coude et il faudra demander à
mes interlocuteurs quelle a été leur
réaction mais j'ai le sentiment que le
climat et les débats qui ont eu lieu
avec tous les partenaires ont été enfin
moi le sentiment que j'en retire
si c'était positif une certitude
au terme de cette journée marathon
laurent fabius a tenu ses promesses
il est venu en lorraine il a apporté des
emplois c'est un gage de crédibilité
pour une lorraine habitué aux espoirs
déçus
cela dit deux problèmes subsistent
comment convaincre la cgt est avec elle
le conseil régional de lorraine
comment les convaincre donc que l'heure
n'est plus à la révision du plan est
deuxième problème comment au-delà de
l'opération pilote d'aujourd'hui
continuer d'attirer les industriels en
lorraine il y a encore pour la
sidérurgie 12000 postes à trouver
oui le social toujours avec la direction
des chantiers navals normes aide qui
maintient son plan de réduction des
effectifs
c'est ce qu'annoncent les syndiqués au
terme d'un comité central d'entreprise
3325 emplois devraient disparaître sur
10 1836 et puis une confirmation la
hausse des prix pour le mois de mars a
été de +0 7%
c'est le chiffre officiel publié tout à
l'heure par l'insee conclusion immédiate
l'inflation aura été de 2% pour le
premier trimestre de cette année
vous savez que le gouvernement souhaite
imiter cette inflation à 5 % pour
l'ensemble de l'année 84
les manifestations se suivent et ne se
ressemblent pas aujourd'hui ce sont les
professions libérales qui défilaient à
paris à l'appel de l'unapl ils étaient
cinquante mille à manifester avocats
médecins architectes notaires 63
professions libérales défilé cet
après-midi à paris à l'appel de leur
union nationale les manifestants
venaient de toutes les régions de france
sauf la lorraine dont les voies de
chemin de fer ont été coupées ce matin
par les sidérurgistes les professions
libérales protester selon leurs
représentants contre les restrictions de
liberté apportées par le gouvernement à
l'exercice de leur métier et contre la
concurrence déloyale des pouvoirs
publics
si ça continue nous sont plus sinistre
avec la sidérurgie je les dis je sais
que ça fait scandale
c'est la vérité nous allons devenir
sinistrés comme les autres plus que les
autres et demain les français se
réveilleront il y aura une profession
libérale
ils auront des fonctionnaires après
avoir déposé une gerbe au pied de la
statue de la liberté pont de grenelle
les manifestants se sont retrouvés pour
un meeting au pied de la tour eiffel
ils scandaient des slogans hostiles au
président de la république mais la
manifestation s'est dispersée dans le
calme
polémique sur le nombre de manifestants
hier lors des défilés pour soutenir
l'école publique des chiffres
extrêmement difficile à déterminer avec
précision ce qui est sûr c'est qu'il y
avait plusieurs centaines de milliers de
manifestants au défilé de paris par
exemple
mais chacun avance le chiffre qui
l'avantagent le plus une nouvelle preuve
des difficultés qui lie attentif y ait
de tels grande manifestation sur le plan
politique à noter que le député
socialiste andré laignel vient
d'annoncer que le parti socialiste
allait donner mandat à son groupe
parlementaire afin que le projet de loi
savary soit améliorée et que les laïcs
s'ils reconnaissent les six viticulteurs
arrêté hier après l'incendié criminel du
centre leclerc de carcassonne les six
hommes ont été placés en détention
provisoire
ils risquent de 5 à 10 ans de prison et
de 5000 à 200 mille francs d'amendé
les comités d'action viticole de la
région se sont immédiatement réunis pour
envisager une riposte après ces
inculpations
une petite phrase du président de la
commission européenne monsieur gaston
thorn qui a rencontré tout à l'heure
françois mitterrand à l'elysée
et cela à la veille du voyage en italie
du chef de l'état pour monsieur thorn
on ne peut pas spéculer indéfiniment à
la baisse contre l'europe et c'est
maintenant l'heure de la vérité monsieur
thorn souhaite que l'on trouve une
solution aux problèmes les plus délicats
avant le sommet des 24 et 25 juin
prochains
un jeune homme retrouvé mort dans sa
chambre d'hôtel aux états unis ce serait
un fait divers banal si le jeune homme
en question ne s'appelait pas des vite
kennedy c'était l'un des enfants du
sénateur robert kennedy assassiné en
1968 cinq ans après son frère john
kennedy une nouvelle marque du destin
sur cette famille déjà très éprouvé
jean-claude d'arrigo il avait la
fortunée
noms prestigieux david anthony kennedy y
est pourtant on a retrouvé son cadavre
ici dans l'une des chambres d'un hôtel
de palm beach en floride accident
cardiaque overdose
on attend les conclusions de l'enquêté
david qu'elle ait dit de même que son
frère était de toute façon connue pour
ses problèmes avec les stupéfiants
il était le quatrième des onze enfants
de bob kennedy est probablement celui
que l'assassinât de son père avait le
plus perturbé voilà un enfant qui a 7
ans quand son oncle moeurs et 12 quand
son père meurt il est donc tout à fait
conscient l'époque de la tragédie qui
s'abat et sur lui sur sa mère et sur les
autres îles la vie et surtout ce qu'il
vit c'est le manque de pair le manque
donc le manque d'une autorité de tutelle
car bien sûr il ya teddy le dernier
m'étais dit si il peut pas à lui tout
seul à être le père de 14 au 18 enfants
garçons et filles et par conséquent
voilà des enfants qui d'une part sont
porteurs d'un nom prestigieux mit
quitter la fois un nom très lourd à
tenir assumer deuxièmement assez riche
pour un peu croire qu'ils font à peu
près ce qu'ils veulent et troisièmement
il n'y a plus de fibres ya plus une
autorité suffisante pour les tenir
alors ils vont un peu dans toutes les
directions ils passent à travers l'état
des preuves et pourvu que la fibre
morale ou physique soit un peu plus
fragiles ou faible que d'autres ils
peuvent se laisser tenter par la drogue
donc moi ce que je dis c'est
qu'évidemment c'est l'illustration de ce
qu'on peut appeler la tragédie kennedy
qui hélas ça n'est qu'une épique un
épisode mais il faut bien voir aussi
c'est une autre illustration beaucoup
plus générale c'est qu'à partir de
l'instant dévide kennedy a touché une
fois à la drogue à cette drogue dure
il s'est est condamné à mort à plus ou
moins long terme
il ya deux choses dans cette affaire il
ya la tragédie d'une famille célèbre
mais il ya d'autre part le fait qu' on
ne touche pas à la drôle parce que la
drogue tue qu'on soit un chanteur de
rock célèbre un petit noir inconnu du
ghetto où un kennedy
nous espérons que david a enfin trouvé
la paix qu'il n'avait pas connu pendant
sa vie a déclaré edward kennedy l'oncle
de david
une phrase qui hors des grands débats
politiques montrent les kennedy tels
qu'ils sont aujourd'hui une famille
marquée une nouvelle fois par le malheur
21 coups de canon le chinois avaient
bien fait les choses pour accueillir
ronald reagan à pékin une bienvenue dans
l'effort mais qui ne manque pas d'une
certaine saveur
lorsqu'on se souvient que le président
américain était récemment encore l'un
des adversaires les plus farouches de la
chine communiste
mais c'est aujourd'hui le tank du
réalisme ronald reagan est aux affaires
et l'élection présidentielle pointe à
l'horizon le numéro américain va donc
rester six jours en chine
il aura 10 heures d'entretiens avec les
dirigeants de ce pays
jean marc il nous respecte nous trop
perd la tête 4 mot en chinois pour dire
un milliard d'hommes respect mutuel
bénéfice mutuel voilà pour le premier
message de ronald reagan à la chine la
chine populaire qui a finalement déroulé
son plus beau tapis rouge pour un
président américain dont la vieille
amitié envers l'autre et chine la chine
nationaliste reste toujours bien
coupable aux yeux des dirigeants
communistes de pékin au nom du respect
mutuel on fermera donc un instant les
yeux sur le différend idéologique reste
donc les bénéfices mutuels
le candidat reagan avait besoin de ce
voyage là pour redorer à la télévision
américaine
une image internationale bien ternie par
l'échec américain au liban
la chine elle veut jouer la carte de la
modernisation de nouveau une politique
d'ouverture sur l'extérieur à raison
économique bien sûr et quel meilleur
partenaire que la puissante amérique
pour par les investissements et surtout
coopération nucléaire
une amérique qui de pékin veut aussi
faire savoir à l'urss qu en asie comme
en europe
la puissance militaire soviétique
inquiète et qu'à défaut de pouvoir en
parler
l'amérique réarmer de ronald reagan
c'est être entendue du plus grand pays
communistes du monde respecte trop la
fête au brésil les députés ont rejeté
l'amendement qui prévoyait l'élection du
président de la république au suffrage
universel c'est donc la déception et la
tristesse pour les partisans de ce mode
de scrutin qui avait manifesté en masse
ces dernières semaines pour tenter de
convaincre leurs représentants de voter
ce texte
au liban le président de la république
monsieur gemayel a désigné le premier
ministre il s'agit de monsieur rachid
karamé c'est un musulman sunnite
considéré comme l'un des alliés les plus
fidèles de la syrie la preuve s'il en
était besoin de l' influence
grandissante de damas dans la politique
libanaise
par ailleurs un gendarme français a été
tué tout à l'heure à beyrouth il était
abattu de deux balles tirées à partir
d'une voiture alors qu'il gardait
l'ambassade de france c'est le deuxième
attentat anti français depuis le départ
des marsouins ou début de ce mois nuit
bleue en guadeloupe où 14 attentats à
l'explosif ont été commis la nuit
dernière ils n'ont pas été revendiqué
pour l'instant lé dernier attentat
remontait au 4 février dernier
des dégâts importants mais pas de
victime
en guadeloupe ces attentats visaient des
objectifs symboliques de la présence
française
ainsi par exemple la pointe à pitre
trois attentats ont eu lieu devant la
maison d'arrêt la gendarmerie et la
chambre de commerce
d'autre part ont été visés la perception
de sainte rose
la nouvelle gendarmerie de sainte anne
et la perception de port louis ces 14
attentats ont été commis aux environs de
4 heures heure locale et toutes les
charges étaient de faible puissance
les premières constatations laissent à
penser que les poseurs de bombes qui ont
agi de façon parfaitement synchronisé
cherchait avant tout l'action
spectaculaire cette série d'attentats
est jusqu'à présent non revendiqué
cependant elle pourrait être attribuée à
lacq l'alliance caraïbes révolutionnaire
organisation indépendantiste en lutte
contre toutes les formes de
représentation française
en guadeloupe le 14 novembre 83 elle
avait revendiqué l'attentât à la
préfecture de basse terre
cet attentat avait fait 23 victimes
berleur pescayre reconnu coupable de
cinq assassinats dont celui de sa femme
vient d'être condamné à la réclusion
criminelle à perpétuité pas de
circonstances atténuantes et jurés de la
cour d'assises de paris ont mis moins
d'une heure pour arrêter leur sentence
vous allez maintenant voir un document
que vous n'oublierez pas un de ces
documents qui donnent froid dans le dos
et qui pourtant pose une question
fondamentale les malades qui souffrent
qui sont incurables
ont-ils le droit à la mort un médecin
allemand vient de relancer ce débat en
fournissant à une malade qui souffrait
terriblement une dose de cyanure et pour
que les choses soient claires et que le
débat soit véritablement posée sur la
place publique
il a publié un compte rendu de cet acte
de même qu'une bonne vidéo tournée à
cette occasion vous allez le voir cela
pose une question vraiment terrible
michel meyer
cette femme de 69 ans défiguré par le
cancer ne veut plus vivre après treize
opérations et l'implorent son chirurgien
le professeur aké talent de la libérer
de lui offrir le moyen de mourir une
scène filmée par le professeur lui-même
à destination de la justice pour prouver
la volonté de la malade
cette femme désespérée est morte deux
heures après ce dialogue après avoir
avalé un gobelet de cyanure que lui
promet ici du lieu où sa cote à ce
poison lui a toutefois été administrées
par l'une de ses proches
j'ai la conviction nous dit ici le
professeur à que talent que nous devons
dans des circonstances et cas précis et
contrôlables dépasser la situation et la
loi actuelle les médecins ont le devoir
d'aider de façon active certains malades
à mourir je souhaite même que cela
devienne encore plus agréable pour les
patients avec mise en place d'un goulag
août en présence des proches réunis
autour du lit au moment même où le
malade sans dormir
il reste que la justice allemande aura à
se prononcer sur l'acte d'euthanasie du
professeur aké talent en termes de droit
il n'a pas tué mais seulement donné à
une malade les moyens de se suicider est
encore à travers une tierce personne
mais son geste est devenu le thème de
conversation numéro un du congrès de
chirurgie qui se tient en ce moment à
munich le monde médical allemand est
divisée autant que les juristes
d'ailleurs dans un débat qui ne fait que
s'enflammer alors après ce document qui
pose le problème de façon extrêmement
violente nous avons voulu avoir la
réaction d'un grand cancérologue
français qui est souvent confronté à ce
genre de situation le professeur léon
schwartzenberg votre réaction à chaud
venez de voir ce document qu'en pensez
vous c'est un document terrible terry
parce que le rôle d'un médecin c'est
surtout d'un cancérologue c'est que
guérir le plus souvent possible de faire
vivre le plus longtemps possible et de
permettre de vivre le plus
confortablement et le moins
malheureusement vous même vous avez déjà
été amené à faire ce le même genre de
choses que ce médecin allemand salaires
pratiquer l'euthanasie
malheureusement oui j'avais vu le visage
de cette femme défigurée meurtri la vie
avait déjà disparu de son visage elle me
rappelle les vieilles dames qui meurtrit
elle aussi me disait vous pouvez pas
comprendre
pour vous la couleur du ciel et les
bleus pour moi elle est grise le matin
qui se lève est toujours un matin
terrible et des moines m'épargner des
matins et le visage de cette femme fait
souvenir d'une jeune fille de la région
de bordeaux dans la moitié du visage
gardait le souvenir admirable de son
visage
passé et l'autre moitié était mordu par
une tumeur sanglant nauséabonde et samir
téléphoner désespérée en disant ne peut
rien faire
il reste une carabine et je n'ose pas
l'utiliser j'y retournerai après contre
moi heureusement cette jeune fille a pu
s'endormir paisiblement
est ce que ce n'est pas un pouvoir
exorbitant pour les médecins que de
décider qui va vivre qui va mourir a le
pouvoir exorbitant c'est malheureusement
ne pas pouvoir guérir si je pdc celm
l'absence de pouvoir mais il s'agit d'un
problème de conscience je crois que
cissé qui s'est posé à ce médecin
allemand et j'imagine qu'il a dû montrer
le film parce que c'était trop lourd à
supporter tout ça il a voulu faire
partager son drame par les
téléspectateurs allemands et
éventuellement parler nous vous savez
quand vous êtes confrontés à ce problème
de toute façon la réponse est mauvaise
si vous n'accordez pas la distraie la
disparition de l'existence impossible
vous êtes sauvage vous est cruel puis si
vous l'accordé vous n'êtes pas en accord
avec votre métier
alors vous répondez le moins mal
possible certains répondent que le moins
mal possible c'est de laisser la vie
avec une majuscule se poursuivre malgré
tout certains d'autres dont ferait
partie pensent qu'au contraire il faut
respecter jusqu'au bout la vie et le
désir des libertés de la malade ou du
malade et lui permettre de décider
lui-même avant que la mort qui avaient
déjà réservé ce malheureux visage façon
le malade décide mais c'est le médecin
qui va l'aider à mourir par cette
affaire oui bien entendu
jetant à corps entre de conscience est
ce que vous pensez qu'il faut une
réglementation dans le domaine de
l'euthanasier sûrement pas
c'est un problème de conscience qui ne
peut se régler qu'à signer vos danses
espèces d'isoloirs qu'est notre
conscience et celles du malade et je
pense que toute réglementation qui
permettrait à qui que ce soit d'arrêter
une existence réglementation maudite
surtout dans un pays où on vient
la peine de mort je crois qu'il ya un
risque à courir comme dans les actes les
plus difficiles de notre existence
monsieur risque il faut savoir le courir
quitte à signer ultérieurement toutes
les conséquences éventuellement jeridi
goûter l'acte
un procès par exemple merci monsieur un
sujet à ne pas manquer tout à l'heure
sur antenne 2 il fait l'objet d'un
magazine spécial de notre rédaction à
partir de 21h30 son titre un espion qui
vient de l'extrême droite l'un des
leaders de l'extrême droite européenne a
décidé de changer de bord après vingt
années d'activisme
mais avant de se retourner il a emmené
une équipe d'antenne de découvrir ce que
l'on peut considérer comme la face
cachée de l'extrême droite
il révèle notamment la manière dont sont
réalisés et financés certaines
opérations terroristes
un document extrêmement troublant
l'homme en question s'appelle ray il
on connaissait le triste folklore de
l'extrême droite sa musique son
cérémonial mais pour aller au delà des
apparences il fallait à témoins le voici
en 1983 faisant du porte à porte
candidat de l'extrême droite aux
élections en angleterre il a milité 20
ans en europe et en afrique du sud
il se nommerait il à l'origine et
l'habilité contre l'immigration et de
fil en aiguille il s'est retrouvé au
british movement national socialiste
nazi sa fidélité a duré 15 ans quand
j'ai réalisé l'ampleur du danger les
horreurs qui se commettaient les
innocentes l'on brûlait les maisons que
l'on incendiés je suis resté j'ai pensé
que je pourrais faire plus de
l'intérieur qu'à l'extérieur
dans le mouvement d'extrême droite
européens qui êtes-vous
un agent en sommeil son rêve témoigne
donc contre le terrorisme aveugle de
l'extrême droite
ces révélations font remonter les
souvenirs bologne l'attentât 82 victimes
c'est aussi un monde de réunions
occultes qui apparaît au grand jour
ici à los angeles des idéologues
d'extrême droite ni l'importance de
l'holocauste
enfin à paris même régime connaît bien
les appartements qui servent de planck
aux militants d'extrême droite pour des
trafics en tous genres
le
alors pourquoi parlez vous aujourd'hui
pour empêcher des jeunes d'être un peu
vain d'être entraînée sur sur ce schéma
comme comme tous les étés les
révélations de khelil ce sera donc le
thème d'un magazine d'une heure et quart
ce soir sur antenne 2 à 21h30 un
magazine spécial de notre rédaction le
sport avec platini en vedette hier soir
dans la coupe d'europe il a disputé l'un
de ses meilleurs matchs contre l'équipe
de manchester united
une bonne nouvelle à un mois et demi de
l'ouverture du championnat d'europe des
nations
roger zabel enfin quand platini va tout
va et surtout la juventus de turin
vainqueur de manchester par 2 buts à 1
il ya soirée qualifiée pour la finale de
la coupe des coupes michel platini s'est
lui de le plus italien des français
disposent de la meilleure acuité
visuelle du football européen il a vu
boniek et bagnac à vue qu'à gauche de
l'extérieur du pied
il pouvait marquer platini c'est encore
lui non seulement ils voient bien mais
sa précision n'a pas d'égal dans les
pieds de vigne la cour bonini mais bel
est le gardien de manchester est plus
rapide platini c'est toujours lui à
droite
l'air de rien pour tardelli on croit
qu'il s'est arrêté platini mais pas du
tout il frappe mais baylet est encore
bien placé
platini c'est encore et toujours lui qui
ouvre sur bonniec en retrait pour
tardelli qui tombe une fois de plus sur
le fameux bayley et sur ce corner qui va
récupérer le ballon a fait platine bien
sûr passe lobée sur la tête de rossi
baylet détour mais malgré platini
manchester va égaliser après ce secteur
première tentative de my way et le
croiriez-vous le but de la victoire ce
n'est pas platini qui va l'amener mais
j'irai à récupération de
rossi et but vivent à drancy mais vivent
platini et après notre dernière édition
du journal de 23 heures vous pourrez
suivre une édition spéciale coupe
d'europe avec nos spécialistes du
football réunie autour de thierry roland
jack lang a annoncé ce matin une série
de dix mesures destinées à aider la
danse en france des mesures qui
concernent aussi bien les danseurs que
les chorégraphes et les directeurs de
troupes les plus importantes sont la
création de 12 centres chorégraphiques
nationaux dans 12 régions françaises
l'établissement d'un fonds de promotion
chorégraphique dont une commission
présidée par georges hirsch examinera
les demandes aide à la création
outre mesure la création de plusieurs
chaires d'enseignement de danse
contemporaine et classique
enfin de grands travaux devraient
emmener l'école de l'opéra à nanterre et
offrir de nouveaux locaux à la villette
pour le conservatoire de danse sa
silhouette était légendaire à petit
bonhomme tout rond qui effleurait les
touches du piano avec un éternel sourire
en direction de ses musiciens et du
public
quand bézy est mort aujourd'hui à
hollywood il avait 79 ans et c'était
l'une des dernières grandes figures du
jazz qui avait triomphé dans les années
mais quand bézy demeure est un immense
musicien qui n'a jamais cessé de
sillonner le monde à la tête de sa
formation france rof william bill bézy
qui n'étaient pas plus compte qu'elle
hinton était duc mais dans le jazz les
surnoms compte plus que lennon est mort
à hollywood il avait 79 ans depuis
quatre ans il se déplaçait difficilement
à l'aide d'un blizzard petit vélo
électrique
cela n'avait pas empêché la cité de new
york devait fêter son anniversaire en 82
avec lâcher de ballons cadeaux concerts
gratuits service d'ordre
le dernier concert de celui qui avait
accompagné pc snes reçu les conseils de
fass roller jouer avec ella fitzgerald
et linton sarah vaughn ou six autres
comme ils disent oui de combien je
l'écouté je devais avoir 13 ou 14 ans et
en 38 39 points notre code jeune top 6
après la guerre est bien visible revenus
en france
lui-même avec son orchestre en 54 je
m'en souviens c'est un spectre air qui
est formidable parce que c'était le roi
du grand orchestre
sa présence était assez discrète en fait
il jouait du piano très économiquement
tentant une note sur le bout du clavier
mais cette note c'était sa relance est
tous les orchestres puis c'était le
maître du temps pau le maître du swing
du sweat de masse comme avait dit andré
hodeir et y passer à travers les années
les styles toujours fidèle à sa manière
de jouer c'est à dire toujours jamais à
la mode mais jamais démodé il y avait
des solistes formidable avec lui les
arrangeurs excellent enfin c'était
quelqu'un monument dit sûr du jazz et
avec lui je crois que disait puisque dû
qu'à une tonne est mort il ya quelques
années ben je crois que il n'y a plus de
grands chefs d'orchestre le grand
orchestre glace dans cette musique
mais j'apprends à l'instant que les
familles des diplomates britanniques ont
finalement pu quitter la libye aux ont
pu quitter tripoli pour londres cet
après midi après une longue attente
aéroports due à des raisons techniques
apparemment 30 personnes ont pu
embarquer à bord d'un vol spécial qui
donc va rapatrier les diplomates
britanniques qui étaient en poste à
tripoli en libye
et puis les résultats du quarté et
maintenant voilà le panneau il fallait
jouer le 1 le 13 le 10 et le 12 une
combinaison qui rapporte et qui
rapportent bien dans l'ordre puisque le
rapporte 360 3336 francs près de 36
millions de centimes
la calandre différents 30000 278 francs
cela dans les deux cas pour 5 francs
la météo maintenant avec alain
gillot-pétré et des incendies qui ont
commencé un peu partout en france
vous m'auriez dit le midi mais c'est un
monde 16 cents hectares de forêts ont
déjà brûlé en bretagne dans le morbihan
le finistère et les côtes du nord 150
hectares de pins ont été ravagés par le
feu en charente 5 500 hectares de forêt
en dordogne sont partis en fumée jusqu'à
la région parisienne ou cinq hectares
des bois de meudon ont brûlé hier soir
la cause de ces incendies un début de
sécheresse bien sûr dans l'ouest le sud
ouest le centre est
les pluies pour ce mois d'avril sont de
80 % inférieures aux normales
saisonnières 50% pour le sud est hélas
on ne voit pas arriver la pluie car au
dessus de nos têtes l'anticyclone est
coriace il ne bouge pas
regardez l'animation sa lite
satellitaire de la météo nationale
ce ne sont pas ces malheureux nu à ce
qu'ils viennent du danemark et qui se
désagrège comme vous le voyez au fur et
à mesure qu'ils avancent vers le sud se
sont passé malheureux nuages qui nous
donneront beaucoup d'eau canton aux
orages
quant aux orages d'espagne et bien on
les attend on les attend toujours
regardez la carte pour demain c'est du
soleil partout comme ces jours derniers
vraiment du grand beau temps avec
simplement du nord-est au jura et au
nord des alpes
quelques nuages passagers donnant le
soir quelques petites ondées et c'est
pas sûr possibilité d'orages encore
possibilité d'orages sur les pyrénées
partout ailleurs grand soleil après
dissipation de quelques brumes sur
l'aquitaine ce sera la même chose
pendant pendant les deux trois jours qui
viennent côté températures stationnaires
ou en très légère baisse toujours au
dessus des normes saisonnières
17 à 24 degrés sur la moitié nord et de
18 à 25 degrés sur la moitié sud ça ne
bouge donc pas beaucoup demain vendredi
27 avril 3 minutes de soleil en plus
lever 6h36 coucher 21 heures toro à
paris c'est la sainte rita qui est là
qui je l'espère protégera tout le monde
pour les départs de demain ils ont chuté
voici la diapositive départ défavorable
entre 15 heures et 24 heures surtout
pour la région parisienne et surtout
entre 18h et 24 heures ce sera
épouvantable à 22h50 jacques séguy vous
présentera le dernier journal bonsoir
admirateurs